foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday March 6th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
Qualcomm makes chips for smartphones
laptops cars headsets and other devices
and the kinds of tasks that we ask all
of these different tools to do are
getting more complicated
think supporting artificial intelligence
tasks or creating augmented or virtual
realities but qualcomm's CEO Cristiano
Aman sees an opportunity for the company
one he welcomes as the sale of
traditional smartphones Falls hurting
the company's bottom line at this year's
mwc the wsjs journal house hosted a
conversation between Amman and the wsj's
senior personal Tech columnist Joanna
Stern where the two discussed these
issues here are highlights from their
conversation all right
what are you doing Cristiano thank you
so much for being here
very happy to be here we're kicking off
the the show this morning the slowing
smartphone market this is obviously had
an impact on you guys and across the
industry IDC reported 20 drop in the
2022 holiday quarter
lots of people obviously pointing to the
macro environment but also you know
there's this there's been an evolution
in the last couple of years about sort
of the slowing in the innovation in
smartphones and people not needing to
upgrade as frequently is this sort of
the new reality for smartphones in the
short term I think the reality is we're
seeing three factors that impact their
smartphones and uh it's actually very
easy to see we do have a much smaller
Market in 2023 that we had in 22. so
macro had definitely had an impact the
number two issue is uh there's massive
amount of inventories so what we're
seeing right now is a correction number
three Factor was China China is a one a
very significant market and I think
during the pandemic situation in China
the market is also depressed now I find
the most interesting conversation is
your question about what's what's going
to motivate people to buy the next
smartphone and uh you know they're
always going to continue to be things
like uh you're going to have uh you know
faster speeds you're gonna have a better
camera you're going to have a better
graphics you're going to have new form
factors but that's not the most exciting
thing the most exciting thing right now
is AI and if I just look at uh Qualcomm
right now one of the largest uh
processor growth area in our chips is
really AI processing and it's amazing
what's happening with AI outside the
data center we are moving towards this
hybrid AI architecture it's not it's not
efficient or economically viable to you
to apply those large language models for
everything if everything you have to go
to the data center
and the ability to run that locally on
your phone and things that you needed to
do you're going to be chatting with your
phone and you can do that in the phone
and using 5G you can connect the cloud
so those are like one single computer
connected to 5G in between that's going
to be one of the biggest change in user
experience in the next few years so as a
user so I've been using obviously chat
GPT and Bing a lot and things like
stable diffusion and Dolly
there's that delay right you put in your
prompt it goes out to open AI or
Microsoft servers takes I don't know
sometimes a minute sometimes 30 seconds
to a minute maybe longer to get that
return of that information what you're
really promising is better speed there
and because that's happening on the
device yes I want to talk about VR the
things beyond the the smartphone right
now we'll start with mixed reality
you've announced a partnership with
Google it's Google Qualcomm and Samsung
right it's a nice Trio to take on seems
like meta on one side maybe apple on the
other for mixed reality
what are you really thinking of as the
market here who who's going to put on
these headsets I think the opportunity
for user experience is tremendous so I'm
going to give you like a very simple
example how we think about a simple
phone call from a technology standpoint
that will prevent me from rendering like
you right in front of my eyes where
fundamental reality glasses and have a
holographic uh you know phone call so
and then on top of that how are you
going to merge physical and digital
spaces there's we're building digital
twins of everything digital twins are
people digital twins of things and those
devices will actually make the bridge so
we're just at the very beginning already
you've built a digital twin of me
already no but some of the cloud
companies did oh great on that front
though I think lots of people and you
know as a reviewer of these big chunky
headsets where I'm wearing battery packs
on you know backpack size and you know I
look like some sort of cyber org how how
far away are we from what we all want
which are Sleek glasses or Sleek headset
and a low-powered version of that I
think it's an industry where we're
making incredible progress actually I
recommend it just to look on how some of
our reference designs had evolved
they're more and more looking like
eyeglasses humans will reject walking
around with a big helmet but they are
going to wear something like this you
have the ability to leverage uh the
cloud and 5G to be able to do a lot of
the processing in the cloud together
with the device you can connect to your
phone and I think at the end of the day
you should think about you're going to
have your phone and you're going to have
your glasses that's how it's going to be
in the future you showed at CES this
very cool concept car and it seems like
you offer a lot of options I was on the
Qualcomm website last night looking at
eight different things for automakers
from connectivity to the the screen
stuff what are you seeing from the
automakers what are they wanting the
most right now yes
it's if you if you were an investor
right now and you're looking into a car
company you're going to ask a car
company two questions first question is
are you electrical and the core
companies they see if they have a lot of
great plans how
um they're dealing with batteries
electrical mortars and then they're
going to ask the second question are you
digital and I think that's where we come
in what we have done we identify the
opportunity not to think about
components or chips for for different
systems in the car but can we create a
platform connect the car to the cloud
100 of the time provide a card to cloud
service platform
Drive the digital cockpit experience all
those different screens in the car and
then provide Adas assisted driving and
autonomy all in one platform very
scalable we also took some of the DNA we
have for phones and we now enable in a
single chip that you can do Adas and
digital cockpit and it's a it's really a
revolution because it's really meeting
the needs of what the core companies
need to go digital if you look at for
example I'll pick the United States as
an example the core companies didn't
have a direct relationship with their
customers the dealership had but now
with all those screens in the car you
were in contact with your customer a
hundred percent of the time why not have
a CRM system built in you're going to
see more announcements and more
applications coming to the car you know
you can think about it some of the
conversations we had with Microsoft you
can work from home you can work from the
office you can work from the car and I
think there's an incredible opportunity
for disruption over time some of the
services opportunity for the core
companies in the car will exceed the
profit of selling the car in the first
place
for the car manufacturer absolutely
thank you so much for joining us Chris
my pleasure thank you John and that's it
for today's Tech news briefing for more
Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]